in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 31st, on which we commemorate,
our Holy Father Yermannus, Bishop of Auxerre.
Our glorious Father Yermannus, the most illustrious of the Holy Bishops of Gal, after St. Martin,
was born in about the year 378 into a wealthy and powerful family of Auxerre.
He received an excellent education, first in Gal, and then in Rome, where he perfected his knowledge of law and practice.
After having married a virtuous girl of the nobility, he returned to Gal and exceeded to high office in the provincial government.
Armator, Bishop of Auxerre, having died, the divine will expressed itself through the unanimous voice of the people
and Yermannus was constrained to accept the episcopal charge in the year 418.
Abandoning the service of the world to engage in that of heaven, he radically changed his way of life.
Trading the vanities of the times under foot, he gave his fortune away to the poor, lived from then on with his wife as brother and sister,
and embraced an ascetic way of life, taking humility as his companion.
He laid such austerities on himself that, to the end of his days, his life was nothing other than a long and bloodless martyrdom.
Having renounced all the delights of the table, he ate some ashes before eating his barley bread in the evening, often only once a week.
He was clad all year round in a cloak and tunic that he never changed until they fell into rags.
He wore a rough hair shirt next to his skin and a small bag round his neck containing relics of the saints which worked more than one miracle.
He lay down to sleep, fully dressed, even to his shoes, on a poor pallet filled with ashes.
Getting up after a short rest, he spent the night in continual groaning.
Thus living the ascetic life in solitude, while remaining in the world, entirely concentrated on God, he did not, however, forget the duties of hospitality and opened his house to all, washing the feet of his guests and serving them at table in imitation of the Lord.
At the very beginning of his episcopate, he founded a monastery dedicated to St. Cosmos and Damian across from the city on the right bank of the Ion and divided his time between prayer with the monks and the teaching of the clergy and the people in the cathedral.
Christ's charity, growing in him through his valorous striving, overflowed onto his people in streams of mercy and miraculous acts.
It was thus that he helped a tax collector to retrieve the money he had mislaid and which a possessed man had seized.
He healed the children who had fallen victim to an epidemic of diphtheria in the city, with oil that he had blessed, and also delivered many of the possessed and showed himself to all as a steward of divine mercy.
At that time, the Pelagian heresy, which had spread from Rome all over the west, had found particularly fruitful ground in Great Britain, Pelagius's homeland.
The Orthodox of that country then sent a deputation to the bishops of Gaul, who, having assembled in council in the year 429, appointed St. Germannus and St. Lupus of Troy to go and fight against this heresy which taught that man gifted by God with free will, was able to practice virtue and attain to good without the help of divine grace.
Going down the sand, the two bishops stopped one evening in the village of Nantair. A young girl, Genevieve, was brought to St. Germannus, and he blessed her and awakened her to the religious life.
During the channel crossing, Germannus calmed a storm raised by demons, scolding the troubled waters as Christ once had, and pouring a little oil on them.
The two bishops, warmly greeted by a great crowd, did not hesitate to show the superiority of the true faith, both through their teaching and their miracles.
The faithful were confirmed, and those who had gone astray were converted in great numbers, so that the whole country was soon ready to find the unity of the faith afresh, alarmed by the metal of the preachers, the heretics hid until the day when they resolved to engage in a public debate, after being assured of the help of a number of followers.
After having left their opponents, the opportunity to deliver their hollow discourse, the blessed prelates then spread the word of the gospel, powerful as thunder, to which the heretics could find no reply.
The crowds, greeting the bishops' victory with great cries, wanted to lay hands on the impostors, and the two bishops were scarcely able to restrain them.
This victory was confirmed by the healing of a blind girl, which Germannus brought about by placing the reliquary that he always carried with him over her eyes.
From that time, the people received orthodox teaching with avidity, and the peace of the church being assured, the two bishops went to give thanks at the tomb of the holy martyr Alvin, in whose honor St. Germannus dedicated a church on his return to oxer.
This pilgrimage completed, the saint broke his foot, and was lying bedridden when a fire broke out around his lodging.
While the desperate crowd was trying to get to him, he did not allow them to move him, and the flames passing over the house, left it intact, but destroyed all the surrounding houses.
Having been healed, after a white clad angel appeared to him, Germannus continued his journey to Gaul.
In the meantime, the coalition of Saxons and Picts attacked the Bretons.
The terrified people had recourse to the two holy bishops, who, from the moment of their arrival in the camp, gave courage to the soldiers, as though providing numerous reinforcements.
They taught them during Lent, and having made a church of branches, baptized a great many of them on Easter day.
The arrival of the enemy was then announced. The neophytes immediately removed their baptismal garments to take up arms, and Germannus, as their commander, advised them to make an ambush in a sunken valley.
When the attackers fell on them, the two bishops gave voice to a threefold hallelujah, as a war cry, and this, taken up by the entire army like a roll of thunder, put the enemy to flight, many of them perishing in the stampede.
After having thus carried off such resounding victories over visible and invisible enemies, with peace and security being restored on the Great Island, the two saints returned to their own country.
As soon as he was back in Xer, Saint Germannus took up his pastoral activities once more, helped by God's grace.
Its citizens, crushed by an extra tax, also turned to him like children to their father. With compassion for their suffering, he undertook a journey to Arles, the seat of the prefecture of Gaul, to obtain a lessening of the tax.
Traveling throughout Gaul with a small escort and a modest mount, but bearing Christ in his heart, he scattered miracles and clear signs of divine mercy as he passed.
Although he tried to travel in Cognito, the people of all the towns and cities drawn by his renown, hurried to him with their sick, their women and children, to ask his blessing and drink from his inspired words.
Received in Arles as a worthy successor of the Apostles, he was a guest of his friend, Saint Hillary, who often visited him to talk together about the ecclesiastical affairs of Gaul.
Oxiliaris, the prefect, captivated by the saint, showed him particular deference, and, after the healing of his wife, who had long been wasting away through a fever, willingly gave him the tax relief that he was seeking for the people of oxer, and heaped presence on him.
After a further mission in England in the year 440 to fight against a resurgence of the Pelagian Heresy, Saint Yermannus returned to oxer, closely followed by a delegation from Armorica, Brittany, asking for his help.
As Patricius Atius, who was governing the empire, had asked the savage gore, King of the Allens, the federated barbarians, whom he had settled in the Orleans region, to punish their rebellion with a bloodbath.
Taking the road in great haste, the elderly bishop went to confront gore. He first begged him through an interpreter, and when the latter tried to repulse him, Yermannus laid hold on his horse's bridal, thus stopping the leader and the whole army that was advancing behind him.
Instead of being angry, gore was filled with admiration, listened to his request, and told his troops to move back.
Yermannus had, however, to leave immediately for Ravenna, the capital of the Western Empire, to obtain confirmation from Emperor Valentinian III, and Patricius Atius of this provisional favor,
given by gore.
Stopping in Alessia, with his friend the priest Senatorus, he healed a dumb girl, and then took a touching farewell of his friend, knowing that he would not return alive from this journey.
He crossed the Alps, carrying on his back the burden of a crippled and aged traveler whom he had met, and then carried the man himself across a ravine on his shoulders.
Scattering alms and resplendent achievements on the way, the saint arrived in Ravenna.
Once his glorious reputation had preceded him, and where he was received with honor by the bishop, Saint Peter, Christologus.
Empress Gala Placidia had a great dish taken to him, filled with exquisite food which Yermannus distributed among his servants.
He kept the dish to give its price to the poor, and sent back to the Empress a small wooden plate bearing a barley loaf which healed many of the sick.
Passing one day in front of a prison full of men under sentence of death, the saint, filled with pity, prostrated to the ground, and called on the Lord.
The prisons' locks and bars were shattered at once, and the prisoners came out, brandishing their chains, and went in line into the church to give thanks to God.
The healings wrought by Saint Yermannus left the whole town full of wonder, and he would certainly have received a general amnesty for Armordica from the Emperor.
If a new rebellion had not aroused the sovereign's anger, and rendered the holy bishop's application useless.
Shortly afterwards, Saint Yermannus revealed to the six bishops who were talking with him after matins, that the Lord had appeared to him during the night to tell him of his coming departure to his true homeland.
He fell ill and asked the Empress, who came to his bedside, to ensure that his body was taken to observe.
For seven days, the people crowded into the house where he was lying to receive his last blessing, and on the seventh day, his blessed soul was taken to heaven on the 31st of July in the year 448.
The Emperor, the Bishop, and the dignitaries divided all that had belonged to him, and an enormous cortege, the number of whose torches outdid the sun for brightness, formed to escort his body right back to Gaul.
Arriving in Agzir, on the 22nd of September, he was buried outside the walls in the Basilica, which then took the saint's name.
The veneration of Saint Yermannus spread widely in Gaul and Great Britain, in which a great number of churches and villages still bear his name to this day.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.